so the witness came out last week and
holy [ __ ] that's a really hard game so
hot in fact that it got me thinking
about all the games but aren't afraid to
throw a wrench in the works and dump
your progress for a while on that topic
here are five of the most infamous
puzzles in gaming one of my favorite
adventure games of all time is still
life it's this kind of gory detective
point and click game with Jack the
Ripper horror but basically it stitches
this baking puzzle that requires you to
have real worlds baking knowledge to be
able to figure it out suffice it to say
I did not Silent Hill 3 also decided to
test the limits of gamers general
know-how when it made us dig back into
our high school Shakespeare to get
through a particular section now while I
was one of those drama kids with a
penchant for Shakespeare there's a good
reason you'll only be hit with this
puzzle if you're playing on the hardest
difficulty the riddle requires you to
observe poetry and break down each
stanza by identifying its route
Shakespeare play to attain a number even
if you could manage that by
cross-referencing with your complete
works of William Shakespeare volume
you'd need to work out the Romeo me
[ __ ] of the last stanza which
alludes to whether you should double
triple or remove each number to finally
leave you with a four-digit code you'll
be dying to hug a demon nurse after
dealing with this puzzle believe me
the longest journey is a fantastic game
but the ludicrous way in which its
protagonist April Ryan decides to
retrieve a key from a subway has gone
down in history as a particularly
infamous puzzle the so-called
rubberducky puzzle requires you to solve
an unrelated puzzle at your apartment to
retrieve a clamp and then scatter
breadcrumbs out your bedroom window to
attract birds and save a trapped rubber
ducky you then pull in an adjacent chain
to retrieve a clothesline chase the duck
downstream re-inflate the bugger and
here's where it gets weird combine your
insulated dusty pal with the clamp and
the clothesline and Bob's your uncle
you're fishing for
key in a subway station the way that
works is the ducts deflate on the way
down which closes the clamp onto the key
and lets you retrieve it since we're
already tying the line between fun and
challenging and oh my god what the hell
am I supposed to do let's talk about the
Babel Fish puzzle from the 1984 text
adventure Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy that's right we're in the land
before game faq essentially you'll need
to grab yourself a Babel Fish which acts
as a universal translator
once it's stuffed in your ear luckily
they're dispensed from a vending machine
unluckily said fish shoots out of the
machine and into a drain no problem I
hear you say simply cover the drain like
in every other adventure game ever if
you do so a cleaning robot snatched it
up because clearly you aren't faster
than a stupid cleaning robot so prepare
to snatch up the robot in your satchel
older first you'll need to have put junk
mail on top of the satchel to distract
yet another cleaning robot this will
result in the Babel Fish soaring
gracefully into your ear hole thankfully
little cleaning robots are distracted by
exclamation marks and bright colors just
like us the cherry on top is that there
are only five fish in the machine so
screw up this random series of events
five times and you'll inevitably lose
the game and need to start over
it's a damn delight Gabriel Knight has a
problem and I don't mean the vampires
that he's up against in the game blood
of the sacred blood of the Damned I mean
the fact that he wants this really cool
bike but unfortunately it's reserved for
another dude
Anto one of the stupidest puzzles in
gaming and its most basic level this one
isn't so crazy you want to impersonate
this guy so you steal two dudes jacket
from his hotel room grab a hat so you
can pretend you aren't blessed with the
beautiful blonde mane you have and grab
the schmutz passport out of his back
pocket would it have been easier to just
steal the damn bike at this stage
probably but it gets better
Gabriel needs a fake mustache to really
sell the disguise there are two problems
with this one to get said mustache you
need to find a hole in a door attach a
piece of tape to the hole scare
a cat into running buy it and put the
nail cat heck of a tape on your face by
affixing it with syrup then there's my
second issue the guy you're
impersonating does not even have a
mustache the puzzle ends by you needing
to draw a mustache on the passport with
a marker the mind really does boggle
Piera adventure games have never had all
that much about being too difficult
in fact I've had many playthrough is
where I figured out I missed something
ages ago that I needed to pick up and
now my options were either to start all
over again or quit playing I often went
with the latter perhaps the worst puzzle
of the lot though with in 1984 'the
king's quest where you needed to guess
the name of an infuriating little-known
you'd be on the right track for wanting
to guess Rumpelstiltskin but you'd be
wrong checking it to the witch's house
from Hansel and Gretel and hopping a dig
around will reveal a note that reads
sometimes it's wise to think backwards
if you manage to find and understand
that good on you
but spelling Rumpelstiltskin backwards
also won't work what does work is
reversing the entire alphabet and
swapping out each letter in
Rumpelstiltskin for its corresponding
letter in the backwards alphabet and the
answer is clearly in cough Grubb Crump
rest in peace the sanity of all
adventure gamers in the eighties
interestingly the 1990 remake of the
game does except Rumpelstiltskin spelled
backwards as an acceptable answer let me
know what the toughest puzzle you've
ever beaten is down in that comment box
and I will see you with a brand new
episode next week